imagine que tu prennes une fourchette et
que tu l'enfonces dans ta Mar et que tu
commences à tomber au fond de ta boîte
cranienne c'est le grand moment pour
Salma 3 minutes pour convaincre un jury
en lisant un extrait du livre de son
choix pour elle ce sera mortel adelle
écrit par Antoine Dole et Dianne
lefeilleur l'histoire d'une fillette au
fort caractère décidé à mener la vie du
à ses proches un roman amusant que Salma
a voulu partager avec ses camarades pour
le concours des petits champions de la
lecture je trouvais que l'extrait que
j'ai pris bah il était très drôle et bah
d'ailleurs ça a été le cas vu que la
première fois que j'ai lu il y en a qui
ont
rigolé du coup bah ça m'a fait plaisir
moi j'espère déjà que je vais réussir à
me qualifier et après toujours viser
plus haut ce jeudi 18 janvier une
centaines d'enfants venus de huit
classes franciliennes disputer la finale
école au château de Versailles une
première étape de sélection pour ce
grand jeu de lecture à voix haute
proposé aux élèves de CM1 CM2 éloquence
posture et transmission des émotions du
texte était scru par les membres du jury
l'objectif donner le goût de la lecture
dès le plus
jeuneur souvent le fait de lire à voix
haute pour un public créer un déclic
chez des enfants qui sont pas forcément
encore lecteurs ça leur donne envie de
lire de de pouvoir réaliser cette
lecture devant les autres d'être aussi
évalué par les autres dans la classe
parce qu'ils se donnent des conseils
entre eux j'aime beaucoup lire et
j'aimerais montrer à tout le monde que
je sais bien lire grâce au micro bah je
sentais mon cœur battre et il btait
assez vite mais quand j'ai terminé ma
lecture je me sentais beaucoup mieux
donc on a fait beaucoup de plaisir et il
s'agit donc de
Salma un nouveau chapitre débute pour la
jeune Salma gagnante de sa classe le
mois prochain elle disputera l'étape
départementale avant peut-être de
concourir à la finale nationale à la
Comédie française à Paris dans les
yvelin 176 classes participent à cette
11e édition des petits champions de la
lecture pire des